mein sohn ist immer krank
er näherte sich den gesund
nein das ist wasser
das problem
nein das ist wahrscheinlich das problem
er mag werde früchte noch gemüse
er mag wehte früchte noch gemüse
am liebsten ist er sowohl pommes als
auch kuchen
gehen wir zusammen schwimmen
nein ich kann nicht schwimmen
gehen wir zusammen ski fahren
nein
das geht auch nicht ich kann weder
schwimmen noch ski fahren
ich kann weder schwimmen noch ski fahren
christian warum suchst du einen neuen
job
ich habe
dieses jahr noch letztes jahr eine
lohnerhöhung bekommen
ich habe
dieses jahr noch letztes jahr eine
lohnerhöhung bekommen
kommst du in die disco
ich kann nicht an
ich kann nicht tanzen
dann gehen wir ins karaoke dann gehen
wir ins karaoke
nein ich kann weder tanzen noch singen
wann können wir uns treffen
ich habe weder morgen noch übermorgen
zeit
ich habe weder diese noch nächste woche
was schenkst du deine freundin zum
geburtstag
ich bin
nicht sicher
ich schenke ihr entweder einen ring oder
ein wellness wochenende
ich schenke ihr entweder blumen oder
schokolade
was schenkst du deinem mann zum
hochzeitstag
ich schenke ihm entweder eine drohne
oder ein neues fahrrad
ich habe hunger
[Musik]
entweder kochen wir etwas zusammen oder
wir bestellen eine pizza
was macht dir in den ferien
entweder gehen wir in die berge oder wir
bleiben zu hause
entweder gehen wir in die berge oder wer
marco wo bist du
ich bin draußen auf dem balkon
aha
du rauchst schon wieder
entweder du hörst mit dem rauchen auf
oder du kannst hier ausziehen
was möchtest du nach dem studium machen
entweder mache ich eine weltreise oder
ein praktikum bei einer firma
wie gefällt dir die neue arbeitsstelle
super sie ist sowohl gut bezahlt als
auch in der nähe
immobilien am rhein guten tag
berührt sie frau am rhein her spricht
karl kurz ich interessiere mich für die
drei zimmer wohnung ist die wohnung noch
frei
ja die wohnung ist noch frei aber es
gibt schon ein paar interessenten
ich habe noch ein paar fragen zur
wohnung gibt es im badezimmer eine
badewanne oder eine dusche
beides es gibt sowohl eine badewanne als
auch eine dusche
es gibt sowohl eine badewanne als auch
eine dusche
auf dem inserat steht miete 1400 franken
ohne nebenkosten was bedeutet das
[Musik]
sie müssen sowohl für den strom- als
auch für die heizung noch extra bezahlen
gibt es eine waschmaschine in der
wohnung
[Musik]
ja es gibt sowohl eine waschmaschine als
auch einen trockner
es gibt sowohl eine waschmaschine als
wann kann ich die wohnung besichtigen
geht es morgen
das geht nicht ich kann weder dienstags
noch mittwochs ich kann weder dienstags
noch mittwochs entweder am 6 oder am 17
august entweder am 6 oder am siebten
august was passt ihnen besser am 17
august perfekt dann habe ich noch keine
termine
sie können die zeit wählen ich habe
sowohl am morgen als auch am nachmittag
zeit
ich habe sowohl am morgen
auch am nachmittag zeit
mir würde es um 15 uhr gut passen
das geht also am 17 august um 15 uhr
wenn ihnen die wohnung gefällt und sie
sich dann gleich bewerben möchten
bringen sie bitte sowohl eine passkopie
als auch einen lohnausweis mit wenn
ihnen die wohnung gefällt und sie sich
dann gleich bewerben möchten
bringen sie bitte sowohl eine passkopie
als auch einen lohnausweis mit
je schneller sie uns zu sagen desto eher
bekommen sie die wohnung
je schneller sie uns zu besagen desto
eher bekommen sie die wohnung
ich bringe beides mit vielen dank für
ihre auskunft bis am freitag und einen
schönen abend frau am rhein
danke gleichfalls auf wiederhören herr
kunz
warum arbeitest du so viel
je mehr ich arbeite desto mehr geld
verdiene ich
hast du gelesen was unser präsident
getwittert hat
je mehr er twittert desto mehr schreiben
die medien über ihn
spielst du auch lotto heute sind 100
millionen euro im jackpot
nein je mehr geld im jackpot ist desto
mehr leute spielen lotto
je mehr geld im jackpot ist desto mehr
leute spielen lotto
und je mehr leute lotto spielen desto
geringer ist die chance als einziger die
sechs richtigen zahlen zu tippen
und wie
mehr leute lotto spielen desto geringer
ist die chance als einziger die sechs
richtigen zahlen zu tippen
wir müssen jetzt wirklich etwas gegen
die klimaerwärmung tun
was schlägst du four
[Musik]
je mehr leute sich vegetarisch ernähren
desto weniger co2 wird ausgestoßen
je weniger man mit dem flugzeug fliegt
je schneller wir auf kohlekraftwerke
verzichten desto weniger co2 wird
ausgestoßen
je schneller wir auf kohlekraftwerke
verzichten desto weniger co2 wird
ausgestoßen
je mehr leute bereit sind geld für bio
und regionale produkte auszugeben desto
umweltfreundlicher produzieren die
anbieter je mehr leute bereit sind geld
für bier und regionale produkte
auszugeben desto umweltfreundlicher
produzieren die anbieter
wie waren deine ferien
nicht nur das wetter sondern auch das
hotel waren schlecht
nicht nur
sondern auch das hotel war
recht hallo mathias imbusch
ja mein auto ist in der werkstatt zur
reparatur
was ist mit deinem auto
die mechaniker müssen nicht nur die
bremsen sondern auch die räder ersetzen
worüber diskutieren die politiker am
treffen
sie diskutieren nicht nur über die
klimaveränderung sondern auch über die
armut sie diskutieren nicht nur über die
klimaveränderung
sondern auch über die armut schreib
deine antwort in die kommentare ergänzt
die satz anfänge wir werden deinen
kommentar lesen und korrigieren
ich muss sowohl die steuern als auch
bezahlen
ich kann weder fliegen noch je mehr geld
die leute verdienen desto entweder habe
ich glück oder gesund leben bedeutet
nicht nur sport treiben sondern auch
möchtest du noch weitere videos sehen
dann abonniere unseren kanal jeden
sonntag ein neues video
möchtest du noch weitere videos sehen
dann abonniere unseren kanal jeden
sonntag ein neues video